chez elle, que la communauté
Atikamek de Manouane a chois
d'honorer la mémoire
de Joyce Echaquan.
tante de Joyce Echaquan
- Joyce, c'est ma niè..
Ouais.
- On est en 2022, bientôt en
des gens qui souffrent.
Même après ycyce,
ce n'est pas terminé.
notre classe, qui est sa fille.
Ils ont fait u p pancarte pour
Joyce, mais aussi pour Jessica,
parce qu'ils m'ont dit :
n'ait pas sa maman".
- J'aiais peur qu'on l'oublie
à petit feu ici.
- Deux ans se sont
depuis le décès de la bien-aimée
de Carole Dubé, deux ans
consacrés à donner vie
CAROL DUBÉ
mari de Joyce Echaquan
- Ça me fait du bien de voirrere
de Joyce. C'est un bon moyen
aussi d'envoyer le message que
ce n'est pas réglé.eieieieieieil
des Atikamekw de Manawan
- Nous, on a tendu la main
au gouvernement avec le principr
comment on devrait travailler.
Le gouvernement n'a pas écouté,
a fait la sourde oreille depuis
- D'ailleurs, cette journée
aurait pu être l'occasion d'un
premier vrai tête-à-tête entrein
et François Legault.
C'est plutôt Ian Lafrenière,
le ministre sortant des affaireu
présent.
IAN LAFRENIÈRE, ministre respo.
Affaires autochtones, Québec
à Juliette, à l'hôpital, et tout
étairéréglé au quart de tour
pour que le premier ministre
soit là. Ici, en communauté,
- Le premier ministre sortant a
totout de même défendu son bila.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT
premier ministre du Québecststs,
on a embauché un adjoint à la
présidente du SSF, on a embauché
des agents de liaison pour faire
la liaison entre lpipipipipipipt
les membres de la communauté.
Puis on a donné une formation
à tous les employés de l'hôpital
de Joliettququququququququququqp
améliorée à l'hôpital
de Joliette.
DOMINIQUE ANGLADE, cheffe, PLQ
-
espéré, après tout ce qui
s'était passé à l'Assemblée
nationale, qu'on soit tous levés
de manière pressenti pour tout
rendus beaucoup plus.
- La famille est bien déterminée
à garder le combat de Joyce
Une poursuite pour tenter
d'obtenir réparation
sera déposée demain.
Ici Amélie Desmarais,